2019 sera l'année internationale des
langues autochtones selon l'unesco il ya
urgence sinon la moitié des 6000 langues
connues sur la planète auront disparu
d'ici la fin du siècle avec 70 langues
autochtones du canada
quand même est un joueur important avec
nous pour en parler marjolaine churchill
et directrice générale de l'institut
tshakapesh et antoine gauthier directeur
général du conseil québécois du
patrimoine vivant
bonjour à vous deux merci d'être là ce
matin dites nous monsieur gautier qu'est
ce que ça veut dire concrètement une
année consacrée aux langues autochtones
d'abord
c'est pour faire foisonner des
instruments internationaux qui existent
déjà qui contiennent des plusieurs
dispositions sur les langues autochtones
et les cultures autochtones
donc on peut penser à la déclaration des
nations unies sur les droits des peuples
autochtones tout les programmes
internationaux sur le développement
durable les lois internationales sur le
travail les droits de l'homme
les conventions de l'unesco sur la
diversité culturelle c'est sur la
promotion et la sauvegarde du patrimoine
culturel immatériel donc contient la
diversité biologique aussi évidemment
contiennent des dispositions sur les
langues et les cultures autochtones
la plupart donc pour prévenir la
disparition des langues et des savoirs
autochtones pour réparer les torts qui
ont été faits par le passé incluant
évidemment au canada et au québec et
j'oserais même dire dans le cas de la
convention 2003 qui est celle sur
laquelle je travaille davantage donc sur
les traditions et savoir tradition orale
et savoir inspiré le reste de l'humanité
sur plusieurs questions nous est-ce que
le fait d'avoir une amie international
des langues autochtones ça peut
contribuer à améliorer concrètement la
vie des autochtones
je vous dirais que l'année
internationale des langues autochtones
va nous permettre d'optimiser la
sensibilisation les communications sur
l'urgence de préserver nos langues
autochtones
c'est une opportunité à saisir pour
sensibiliser à les gouvernements nos
communautés à nos politiciens à
l'urgence d'établir des plans d'actions
concrètes efficaces pour la préservation
et cette urgence
elle est réelle quand on parle
dizaine d'entrée de jeu sur 6000 langues
dans la moitié qui pourraient
disparaître d'ici la fin du siècle
c'est vraiment un verre qu'on s'en va en
2006 tunon statistique canada un tir de
langue autochtone était parlée à la
maison il ya soixante et 5 l'anc à
travers le canada les langues
autochtones y en a dix langues
autochtones au québec elles dont deux
sont déjà du super u qu'est-ce qu'est ce
qu'on pourrait faire ne serait-ce qu ici
au québec au canada pour s'assurer que
ces langues là ne disparaissent pas ben
à travers le monde et incluant le québec
et le canada il ya un paquet de petites
actions et de grandes actions qu'on peut
poser notamment en relation avec
l'éducation des outils pédagogiques des
professeurs évidemment tout ce qui est
communication radio internet davantage
de moyens pour produire du contenu dans
les langues autochtones des arts les
sports les juridique
par exemple au canada c'est désormais
possible pour les députés de s'adresser
aux autres à la chambre des communes
dans dix rondes autochtone
c'est un des exemples possibles le but
étant d'avoir un maximum d'occasions
possible de parler les langues
autochtones pauvres les locuteurs on
disait quoi 70 langues
autochtones au canada c'est ça est ce
qu'elles sont tous en danger ou
certaines qu'elles vous sentez à sont
tous appellent sont tous à dents en
danger il ya certaines langues qui sont
menacés sérieusement à court et à moyen
terme dont la langue est ma langue donc
votre langue qui est vraiment en voie de
donc de disparition et très bonne assez
je vous dirais surtout les communautés
de
l'ess des régions isolées éloignées eux
arrivent à maintenir la langue mais
c'est surtout les communautés à
proximité des villes qui sont menacés
comment votre institut arrive à
participer à garder ces langues vivantes
nous on a les styles gabès ont produit
du matériel pédagogique
on développe des programmes
d'enseignement de la langue hinault dans
nos écoles on crée des lexiques on a
développé beaucoup de cordes opus et
beaucoup dé est très développé on a
développé un dictionnaire l'an i know
français des grands-mères beaucoup
d'histoires pour les lieux pour enfants
et aussi on a beaucoup de collecte de
mémoire aussi de new delhi qui est
essentiel à la sauvegarde de la langue
sinon comme un conseil québécois du
patrimoine vivant qu ont participé et
contribué l'an 2019 avec cette année
internationale des langues autochtones
écoutez j'ai envie de dire que les
grandes choses pour les langues
autochtones en 2019 vont être réalisés
par les locuteurs
c'est à dire continuer à parler leur
langue et la transmettent
du côté du conseil québécois du
patrimoine vivant parmi les petites
mesures on voit qu'on va mettre de
l'avant évidemment essayer de traduire
notre site web
dans différentes langues faire une
demande de désignation ministériel comme
patrimoine immatériel pour le conte en
français et dans les différents
différentes langues autochtones
on a travaillé fort au sein de la
convention de 2003 de l'unesco pour les
cas des états parties soumettre des
candidatures sur les listes en lien avec
les langues autochtones donc ça c'est
une résolution qui est passé en décembre
dernier
on va travailler aussi on essaie de
créer des ponts entre le crespian ça
c'est quinze pays de l'amérique latine
vit le gouvernement du québec pourrait
changer notamment sur la question des
langues et des traditions autochtones et
évidemment mettre en valeur les
activités nos membres tshakapesh
institut avatar wapikoni mobile les
festivals de contes et légendes
dynamique a dit si tu vas l'autoroute 15
commission canadienne pour l'unesco
c'est eux qui font les actions
intéressantes y vont faire beaucoup à
surveiller pour garder ces langues
vivantes faut que les communautés
continuent de parler leur langue ou et
convainc goûter une nouvelle génération
à hal a parlé allait parler c'est
l'anglais et nous également de parler
d'être situation je pense qu'on va le
faire
en 2019 je rappelle que l'unesco donc
qui est proclamé 2009 année
internationale des langues autochtones
antoine gautier marjolaine cerné chez
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
aujourd'hui et et bonne année 2010 ne
connaît pas